yo tout le monde sait squeeze mais parce
qu'en fait il la voix cassée vu dans mon
approche par dans les aigus je n'avais
pas la ferme aux renards passe à autre
chose
regardez hâter la nuit c'est très
dangereux en contre et votre nom mais
cannes et ce jeu oui effectivement on va
voir est très mal bon bah excusez moi ça
irait tout le monde tu es malade en
hiver alors rentrer tout de suite notre
nom squeeze exactement ça on a ajouté
sur bois un jeu qui déjà un nom de merde
alors du coup en groupe vous allez très
vite comprendre le principe du jeu c'est
qu'on regarde la télé donc on consacre
d'échelle comme des histoires ça fait
leur bord acquis qui sont bien chier
20,2 matin up et à thé envolé cette
charge et de chocolat comme ça donc cet
homme change très vite de chaque et dès
que ça apprend que je dois payer / s
voilà donc la regarde chez nous aux icd
un jeu de dames
donc c'est vraiment intéressant et la
madame vient exposer puisque je suis
tombé sur du voile aaa
ok donc j'ai ça fait que 44 fois je j'ai
plusieurs questions après ce jeu la
première pourquoi la personne qui a
gardé l'état cote
pourquoi aller apprenons les
mathématiques à la télé sur le bas un
carré à côté un carré à côté un quart et
un côté là c'est un avion on pourrait
croire que tu de bonbons peu moins de 7
ha ha ha avec sa barre de droite qui est
quelque peu obèses
non ça va bien jay-z l'appartement de
cet homme est très étrange à ces jeunes
qui habitent en 1 / ap on voit là c'est
un bon voilà on a même des voitures tout
de suite comme ça voilà mais bordel
qu'est ce qu'il fait ce code
quoi quoi j'avais vu un mec plein de
vidéos il y avait sur la tête et bat non
maman aussi jongleurs professionnel
depuis 1760
mais merde taione météo merci l'abonné à
105e chaîne
le scribe à être là tout moment et nous
faire peur un peu comme ça attention aux
coups j'ai peur aux jeunes parents ma
voix
le gameplay et le plus passionnant du
monde tu mon fixe sur de tout ton perso
qui se fait tuer par un clown qui sort
de la tv c'est la d'arrêter le prend de
la drogue mais des fois on est vraiment
sur des jambes mais je comprends pas
alors autant des fois c'est décrit pupin
star ça n'empêche pas que le jeu peut
être bienvenu à chier mais bon il ya une
explication à ogeu autant des fois donc
je me suis fait défoncer par un monstre
qui a un espace de dix mètres entre ces
deux ans devant la gare tul team et cie
on commentait en boulet ouais c'est de
formes géométriques capable juste
derrière la tête
et qu'est ce que c'était est ce que
c'est un mec qui fait des ombres
regarder quelques unes avec d'autres il
a vite fait d ombres chinoises pour me
faire peur
tentez de tapper alors il est donc juste
comme ça mais pourtant de l'autre côté
de la fenêtre vraiment un mec qui fait
et voilà on est lucide et un mystère je
mentais au revoir
your happy to face attendait si je vois
un micro secondes de chaque chaîne par
minute
ceux ci étaient totalement illogique
n'empêche que je pense que ce coq je
m'appelle je crois que c'est ok par
voulez si tu le manges tu à manger pour
10 années notre grève toute la nuit
tous les jours dans sa prudente est en
train de saper il dit là il avant toi y
ait un avant contrat
et voilà je n'ai actuellement plus de
voix car j'ai trop de lait j'espère au
moins que vous aurais aimé cette vidéo
pis
or moi puis vont le prendre voici une
reconstitution du jour de ma naissance
les stations n'ont encore tu as quel âge
j'ai 18 ans le 27 janvier